to assemble the ball valve the
technician places two rubber o-rings on
top of an end cap next is a thick
synthetic ring which will secure the
ball in the valve he seats the valve
body over it
he cleanses the hollow steel ball and
inserts it in the valve body
he stacks more rubber sealers another
synthetic sealer and another end cap on
top he inserts long bolts into the four
corners of the valve and secures them
tightly with nuts to keep air from
seeping into the valve he attaches a
handle to the stem protruding from the
valve body he installs a stop pin to
prevent the handle from opening beyond a
quarter turn finally he tightens the nut
that locks the handle to the valve stem
he now secures the ball valve in a vise
to hold it steady while he tests its
function when the hole of the ball is
aligned with flanges of the end caps the
valve is open and when it's
perpendicular to it its shut satisfied
with its function he transfers the ball
valve to the laser engraver the laser
etches the serial number and other
information onto the valve body
and now one final test the technician
connects the valve to a vacuum pumping
system and activates a leak detecting
device while the pump draws a vacuum he
sprays helium gas on to the valve to
detect any leaks this ensures the valve
will operate properly in a high vacuum
environment some of these ball valves
are manually operated and others are
computerized both versions are designed
to hold up to high vacuum conditions and
handle the flow